PewDiePie: Doki Doki!
(Pewds dabs furiously while making disturbing grunting noises)
Welcome everybody to another episode of "Doki Doki Literature Club!" What I
expected; a cute horror game...
A cute game turning into a horror game
(chuckles)
What I got were "blue balls"! What the actual
Christian channel! Okay! I've been playing this game for more than three hours, and
absolutely nothing, I repeat, absolutely nothing - no indicator
whatsoever that this is a horror game has appeared in front of me. Maybe some fourth-wall breaking, some
foreshadowing that something bad is gonna happen, but my god...
The "blue balls"...
that has [been] bestowed upon us. If something doesn't happen VERY soon they might explode! (ew)
Ah! That would be yucky! (that's what I said)
Uh, where are we? We were - Monday, Monday, Sunday
December 5th! (Pewds makes mouth music)
Here we go.
(Pewds Reading) "I've been getting increasingly anxious about Yuri's upcoming visit" - Right so, it's-it's the weekend we're gonna visit
Yuri or she's gonna visit us we're gonna get it on
Hopefully- (Pewds Reading)"I keep telling myself there's no reason to be nervous but it doesn't help much"
"Yuri is clearly an introvert and also an intimate person in general. There's no doubt that she'll open up a little bit when it's just the two of us"
"Meanwhile we're even been texts- we've even been texting occasionally. "She was extremely apprehensive at first"
"But it wasn't long before i was already learning more about her. But putting Yuri aside..."
"I haven't heard a thing from Sayori since she left the club early the other day"
"It's not like we text each other all the time or anything,
but i've been worried about her in the back of my mind" But you can text her! whaman
Stupid. (Pewds Reading) "Between what Sayori said and what Monika said, is it really ok
for me to put Sayori's feelings aside when she might need me?"
Just, text her. "hey girl, are you ok" let's fuck! Not that hard."- (Pewds Reading)  "I decided to visit Sayori bef- Oh! Ok so he does it (laughs)
Woo! "Before Yuri comes over. Rather than asking i simply tell her i'm coming over much like you we've done in the past"
"Once i reach Sayori's house i knock on the door before entering it myself"
"Again, we used to play so often that we made it a habit of simply entering each other's houses like we were family"
"The house is quiet. Sayori isn't anywhere on the first floor so i assume she's up it on her room"
"It's already strange of her not to run down and greet me. I head up to her room- to her bedroom but i finally find her"
"Hi Pewdsiepie"
"I sit down in her room"
"Sayori forces a smile but it's easy to tell that she's different"
"There's a minute of silence between us"
"You haven't come over like this in a long time, have you?"
"Ah, I guess you're right"
What in the actual is that bird, what is that bird
Isahiburidesu (haven't seen you in a long time) "it's been a long time. Not much has changed, has it?"
"Sayori's room is messy as it's always been. I also recognize the same stuff animal and wall decoration that she's had for years now"
"Eheheheh"
If you came here more often, it wouldn't be such a mess"
"That's because i end up cleaning it for you"
"How come you suddenly wanted to come over today?"
"Aren't you supposed, to see Yuri today?" She knows!
"Yeah but..."
"Wait- how did you know that?"
"Sayori had already left by the time we decided that last meeting"
"Monika told me"
"It's only natural for her to keep me informed about the festival preparations, right?"
I don't know i think monica is being a little sleazy a little bit
Yeah, that's true but what about you aren't you going to be helping monica today if geez
But i'm just happy harry
We didn't plan to be dipper anything ah, so it's just me and yuri then yep
there's more silence between us
Sorry stairs in the random direction
everything about her behavior is really
Uncharacteristic i finally get to the point i just
Wanted to see how you were doing?
after you left on friday
When something's wrong you can't hide it from me i know you too well sayuri so
savory smiles shaking her head
where can you just be looking fair with me
did you take me for
if i think it's sweet it makes it express my feelings
if he didn't make that stupid mistake
then you would need to be worried about me too
He would left come here we have even been thinking about me right
but this it is just my punishment isn't it i'm getting punished for being certain fees i
Think that's why they were decided to have you come over today?
it is winston searching me
sayuri i
grabbed salary by the shoulders what on earth are you saying are you listening to yourself right now i
Know something happened to you
There's no other explanation for you to be like this
So tell me already
until i know i won't be able to stop thinking about it
sayuri gives me an empty smile
you really picked me in the trip ptp
bit
She gave me your
well
nothing happened to me
festivities you
just, seeing a twitter friend
it's like what monica said she's only cheerful around me and me us
because, she cares about how we think about her but really she carries her own demons
See seeing what what are you talking about saiary?
you're really going to make me say it
i
did she live naturally sustained
the thing is
I've had really be depressing me her leave oh my i can't do that voice now anymore jesus the game just got real
Where do you think i'm late to school every day because most days i can't even find a reason to get out of bed
why reason you said to do anything when i truly know how wisely they say you're a
Why go to school, why eat
Who am a treat why make other people put their energy and character waste by having them spend it on me
that's what it feels like and that's why i just went to me gave me when he
redid anyone wearing it made me
i'm in shock i
Can't even figure out, how to respond
how is it possible let's i already kept this from me the entire time that i've known her
did she really want me once so badly for me to just not think about her
why sorry
why is that that you never told me about this
It almost feel like i've been betrayed as your close friend because if i knew i would have done everything i could to support you
even if there's only so much i could have done good i do i
Would have tried a little harder to make every day a lot better for you and that's why i'm your friend
All you had to do was tell me
You, can see if i told you then you would have to waste every king he bit me instead of doing a burton cheeks?
thank you
my god the worst moment i
Don't want to be cute abate he speeded feet when people tried to gambit me
it feels nice sometimes
But it also feels like a bit being swung against me
yeah
That's why i want it so badly for you to make friends with everyone is
helping everyone be happy together it's a piercing for me
But then i discovered something has to
They make friends and it closed him in everyone in the claim
He feels like a spear going through my head but that's way
that's why they say the word just wants to teach me
every pass please listen baby
yeah
you're right
That i don't understand i don't understand your feelings at all sorry but i don't need to understand
Whatever it takes for me to help you stop hurting that's what i'll do
the only thing that could help is if everything could be like it always was
but they were safest i
finally shoot, he went to her bids me
tears streak down see his face
because i was selfish i
was punished by my heart hurting in a way that i couldn't understand
And now you came here and made you her to
this week until
italy
And that's why i'm going to accept his punishment
Because i deserve a release thank you hurry
Without thinking i once again grabbed so your shoulders this time i pull her in to a tight embrace
sorry i
Don't care if you feel selfish i'm really happy that you convinced me to join the club
Seeing you every day makes it worthwhile enough if i make friends with everyone else then that's just a bonus
But police never underestimate how much i care about you
I wouldn't have it any other way
ptp
Sayuri's hey i'll give me back
Despite my arms being wrapped around her sayuri's arm remain at her sights she starts sobbing next to my ear
I wish i think you were sitting down boys it's so wrong
Sayuri barely manages to speak between our sobs i don't know if i'm doing the right thing
But all i want is for her to know that i care
If you have it in in you to call yourself selfish then you have to let me be selfish too
no
matter what it takes i'll figure out what needs to change i'll make these feelings go away and
If there's anything that you need me to do then you better tell me i'll get mad if you don't
gently sayuri finally puts her arm around me in return i don't know anything
it's already scary i don't understand any of my feelings feasible
the only time i'm not feeling nothing it's when i'm feeling pain but your hugs are silver in this really scary tea
Sorry let me go and she does so i let go as well the festival is tomorrow
it's gonna be fun right
How would you like for me to spend it all with you
it's what i want i promise hey i think there would be mating
yeah
sorry wives her tea ice
If i could spend the whole day here i would of all days
This has to be the one i have other plans?
maybe i should cancel no
please don't if you did that then i really wouldn't forgive you but
It's almost time for uri to meet me at my house
At the very least do you want to come along and help out it would be fun to
my surprise sarah shakes her head
i
don't know i thought if that would be very good for me today
you understand rain huh
It's kind of hard for me to fully understand but i'm trying my hardest
It's okay don't wait to meet you benny i see you tomorrow yuki.
All right i look forward to
Poor sorry she was carrying demons all this time i say goodbye
To see orion exeter house on my way home i find myself still feeling uneasy
But it's hard for me to keep thinking about it when yuri is about
To come over - i think seer is right i shouldn't be wearing too much and we're definitely going
to have a great time tomorrow i
should just focus on what's ahead of me
As i approach my house i see something that makes me feel a moment of panic?
yuri, ah
Ah!
thank goodness
you're a little early
I'm sorry i wasn't home yet
were you waiting for a long time
No, i i just got here but i started to get really nervous when nobody answered the doorbell
you could have always texted me if i know now i would have reassured you and heard more on my way home i
I suppose that's true i didn't think of that for some reason it
Should be common sense to do that but i decided to ignore it
anyway let's go inside
it's weird how the game you know they talk about depression and now they have this music playing in the background it's like okay
i can't drink i
see you brought a lot of stuff with you
that's right and did you manage to find everything ask you to buy as well yeah pretty much
at least i hope i got everything right i'm sure it will be fine i
Take uri to my room the first thing she does is glance around curiously which makes me feel anxious
it's so clean i
Clean it before you came over so make sure there was no
Stain sorry
That's very considerate of you to do ah
no
it would i would be really
really embarrassed for my room to be a mess while you were here hmm well i do enjoy cleaning
this is really the right girl
they will really make the right choice
i would have gladly helped you clean ah
that would have been even more embarrassing
Wait don't look in there i snatch your his wrist while i was in the process of opening a desk drawer mine ah?
I'm sorry i wasn't thinking, for some reason i was just spacing out
it's fine it's fine
i'll let go of yours wrist she puts both her hands firmly in her lap as if making sure she's keeping track of them
So uh should we get started yeah yes
i have a few things planned that you can help with decorations and other atmospheric enhancements
atmospheric enhancements you know mood lightning
aromatherapy
aromatherapy candles wow she brought that
vicious crazy oh wow i didn't know you plan on taking him that far of course i
wanted to help to take our guests
to a faraway place although many will stop by just out of curiosity and for cupcakes i guess i'm
determined to provide an experience that would leave them wanting more
That's great?
It's easy to forget that you're pretty you're a pretty intense person
in tents i
guess that's the best way to put it
it's that up bad thing
No, not at all i'm getting a little tired
and she kept talking about our patience but i'm like i'm right you're getting a lull annoying
it's something that i like it's something that i like about you actually it's that so
that makes me feel relieved and kind of happy
Yeah, no need to be anxious you can relax solo
relax i brought some things for relaxation i
Was going to use them during the poetry even oh yeah like what
let's see uri rummages through her bag she pulls out a few candles and a wooden cylinder shaped object i
did some shopping on the way here so happened to have these in my bag i
plan to cover the windows in black paper and use candles to lit the room i
think that would be amazing but don't you yeah that would be pretty neat
what's the wooden thing though oh
this a dildo it's a diffuser for essential oils of course
half a mil yer ru with aromatherapy therapy
Not familiar at all is that so it's one of my favourite contributors, to have positive atmosphere?
depending on the oils or herbst you choose you can change the mood of the air itself
you, even feel a
permeate through your body you can even feel it permeate through your body
relaxation
energy positive energy romance
reflection it's almost like magic here it takes a cylinder and pushes the switch on the bottle
In just a moment a thin ray of vapor begins to spout through a small hole all the time
wow that smells wonderful
what kind of mood is that one corner
this is a jasmine essential oil for relaxation it smells a little sweet and flowery right
yeah
That's the best way to describe it i choose jasmine for the event because it provides more than relaxation
jasmine enhances your emotions and helps you feel them flow through your body
you feel warming and your heart pounds more heavily don't you think that would be perfect for sharing their poems
it does sound suitable
But, you seem to know a lot about this, so i'll trust you to opinion about
your mood smiles gently
clearly enjoying herself
she again reaches into her bag and pulls at several spools of thin ribbon what are those for well
Did you purchase the origami paper i asked you to get yeah i have it over here?
we won't be using the paper for folding origami
what i'd like to do is write a different bird on each paper we'll need about a hundred of them gss oh yeah
What will those be used for well i'm going to cut pieces of ribbon to hang from the doorway of the classroom
Then we can fasten the paper onto the ribbons to create a doorway
Curtain oh my god that's amazing
wouldn't that be beautiful and
Wood it would also catch the eye of those passing by the room it may attract some to pete inside
that's really creative i had no idea you'd be so good at this uri
it's that so well i suppose i get a little intense as you put it
uri giggles with red cheeks
Is it just me or is she more relaxed minh it's just the two of us
maybe it's the way i've fed that chocolate, to her
like it was mine it's like there's this excitement she feels from sharing something that she enjoys
Here's a mark here's a market pizza pay you can write any character see one i'll help you once i finish cutting the ribbons ah?
all right
sitting on the floor together two of us get to work i
Carefully draw a different character on each paper do my best to manage my bad handwriting
uri unravels a long strand of red ribbon to her desired length
then she reaches into her bag once more and pulls out a pocketknife
Oh, my god it's a horror game after all hey
the knife is strangely beautiful
what it what are you insane
the silver handle has an intricate pattern of waves attached into it
The club the blade itself is gently tinted blue that's no ordinary
pocketknife and mayor say it looks really fancy
well
embarrassed your looks away
what is it
You're going to think it's we you're eight whatever it is i have no reason to judge
To each their own you know?
If you promised you won't be waited to have yeah i promise?
okay all right the thing is i'm kind
thought it thought out you know
you're a girl
Say that shit in new york i'm out i'm out okay oh that's great uh look at the time
It would seem i have to go and find another
they're just so pretty i can't help it i promise not, to be weird enough i
don't know what it is the combination of craftsmanship and feeling of danger maybe
what am i saying please don't think i'm weird for this
you're laughing at me
No, no, i'm not laughing at you
it's just funny how nervous you get about sharing it's well it's an interesting thing to get into i guess
but i think it kind of suits you suits me yeah it's kind of intense
hey
besides it's really cool-looking knife i can't deny that
it is isn't it you're really relaxes our expression once again
would you like to hold it
sure
I'll check it out
yuri carefully answer me the knife
with the handle facing me
And take it and turn it around in my head it feels heavy and extremely solid
where'd you even get a knife like this
curious of its sharpness i feel the point of the knife with my index finger
why did you do that i
didn't expect it to be this shirt i
barely touched it at all
it's my fault i should have warned you this knife is extremely sure it can cut through skin like it's paper oh
no a
small drop of blood trickles down the side of my finger
yuriy takes my hand and gives the wound a closer look huh
She stares at it and noticeably fidgets if
you're, squeamish i'll wash it up now ah
without warning yuri puts my finger in her mouth and licks the wound
that's normal i
feel her tongue karl around my finger
Startled i instinctively pull my hand back oh?
please forgive me i wasn't thinking i
uri lowers her head her face burning up uri that's
The that's the most embarrassing thing i've ever done
how could i have done how could i do something like that
i'm sorry i'm sorry i
Sure it was a little weird and it took me by surprise
but i guess she was just trying to help right
Uri i think you're overreacting alone
Uh-huh!
She doesn't lift her head
What if she doesn't recover from this for the rest of the afternoon
All right you know what this might be stupid thing to do but i'd do it anyway
I take yuri's hand and lick her index finger in return?
did you really just do that now we're even
Uri looks at me like i did something wrong
i
knew that would be a bad idea if not, for the sweet aroma of jasmine oil the air would be extremely heavy right now
You're, so weird pizza pack uri giggles shyly
hey
uri calling me bitch calling me weird
Huh, you calling me weird me i have no response to them
where do you keep your bandages ah i don't think i need one actually it was a tiny cut look it already stopped bleeding i
See that's relieving the tension is quickly lifted we each resumed our respective activities i watched
Uris and i have cut through the ribbon like it's nothing but air meanwhile i continued to make progress on the paper
after we finish attaching the paper to the ribbons we'll lay them all out side by side
it looks better than i expected and will be very effective as a door curtain
it looks great good thinking to come up with this uri you invited all my friends good thinking
Ah thanks it's just something i saw online really
Are you ready to move on to the next task yeah let's do it what do you have in mind?
I'd like to create a banner that's why i asked you to buy the paint tablets, ah
that's right one of the items you read asked me to buy it was a kid of watercolour paint tablets
we'll need about 6 cups of water to put each of the tablets in do you mind fetching those for us
Of course not 6 cups of water come and ratta i'll be right back in a minute
Thank you very much oh?
And just a little bit of water it's ok if you feel the cups too much it will be too diluted
Taking yours advice i decide to use a small plastic
small plastic bathroom cups
rather than full-size glasses i put them on a plate to catch any paint that drips then brings it back into my room
yuri
yes i
she - damn i
Come in to see uri quickly unrolling her sleeve pulling it back over her arm ah?
Nothing your face is a little red is it too hot in here or anything ah
No, not at all there's nothing wrong so let's make the paint
uri uri
Hurriedly dismisses me and takes it upon herself to unwrap the tablets dropping them into the cups
so i
thought we would do something simple that would look very nice
i'd like to paint a gradient across the banner
Starting with the colors for a sunrise then daytime then sunset and nighttime once it drives i'll write an inspirational quote across the banner
we can hang it on the wall behind the podium at the front of the classroom
Oni uh neat what are you gonna write
Well it might be more fun to surprise you nourish smiles of me if you say so
after rolling out the banner you are a knight kneel on opposite sides so we don't get in the way of each other
Uri uses a brush and adds a few dots of different colors across the banner to serve as a color guide when we paint
this kind of reminds me of elementary school
painting on a banner with watercolors feels a lot like art clients projects we had back then it's relaxing
Huh, i'm sorry if this feels too childish
No, i i didn't mean that at all it's kind of fun you know yeah it's fun i'm glad you feel that way too
uri stop spinning for a moment thinking to herself
For me i don't need to go out and do crazy things, to have fun in fact i usually don't even want to
i
just, like when i can spend time with one other person
Even if it's something simple like reading it doesn't even matter if we don't talk much
just, having a friend next to me makes me feel it a little bit nicer i
Think that's all it takes for me to be happy is that so..
even if your and i are quite different i can understand where she's coming from i feel that way about things like anime and games
we're simply sharing the experience with someone can make me feel happy make me happy I..
Think i feel the same way
yuri smiles gently i knew you'd understand
Yuri leans over the banner to grab an unused paintbrush but i move at the same time causing my head to bump into hers
sorry
Yuri realest bet you're a real speck and i quickly lift my hands as a price are you hurt no
No, i'm not hurt
it just started me that's all
Sorry i should have asked you to get it for me it's not your fault
Yeah, oh your face there's drop livable pain on your ears face and neck
is there something wrong on my face
yeah i accidentally got paint on you
sorry it's totally my fault i'll get a towel right away i rush out and
fetch a small towel then i dampen it with hot water i returned to my room kneel back down in front of her
yet i
can't
Hear i pat down your his face and neck with the towel
wow
is something wrong it's hot i just didn't expect it
Sorry i didn't want to use cold water having finished i start to retract my hand but yuri sun-li holds my wrist
my god this is getting crazy
wait
just, for a little longer
it feels really nice uh
i
keep my hand still against your his neck
She looks into my eyes
it's an intense expression that had recognized from when she reads her books
almost as if she's lost in a daze
enveloped by her own but she breeze gently half through slightly parted lips
what is happening is
it the aroma of the jasmine or giving me this dizzy feeling
here is gentles finger wrapped around my wrist sent a tingling sensation through my arm
Suddenly her face seems to be much closer to mine than it was just a moment ago
kiss, her
Huh!
uri slowly pulls away
Sorry i've been feeling a little light-headed today i didn't mean to space out it's fine
The moment is over as soon as it began
Uri picks up her brush again but her movements seemed clumsy like she's unable to focus
i remain silence forced to ignore the event that just transpired i
hasten italy retrieve my own brush and continue following your example
i
should do it i
finished filling the night sky with a white dog with white dots that look like surf looking at the banner as a whole it's
very pretty and natural looking i think it came out better than i expected
i'm really happy with the results yeah me too
are you gonna add the lettering now ah
Not yet i need to it needs
To dry first that's true but won't that take a while well perhaps it would be best, to leave it here
Then have you bring it in the morning i can do the lettering in the classroom before our event starts is that okay
that's totally fun
Wonderful in that case i don't think there's anything more for us to do here i can think of a couple of things?
yeah
you, say that like you're glad it's over
what's i wrong - you assumed that you were at least enjoying yourself a little bit ah
no, that's it's not that it's i'm just glad that we managed to get everything done i
See i am too i was a little concerned about time i need to start making dinner sing ah
So you don't have any time left i was secretly hoping we would have extra time after finishing work well
yuriy thinks to herself i
think it would be too irresponsible of me to wait much longer i'm sorry i
was hoping there would be more time as well
it's probably my fault sorry for being such a slow worker
no, that's not it at all and the important thing is that we've got everything done right
Yeah, so i should be i shouldn't be disappointed or anything
gathering all her things doers seem to look a little down cast i understand why it
Sounded like she rarely gets the opportunity to spend time with friends in a relaxed environment
but that doesn't mean this is the last time it can happen i
feel like just because they said that it definitely is
Once uri packs up i walk her out the front door thank you very much for having me today
no
Problem i'm glad i was able to help just let me know if there's anything else you need me to bring tomorrow i will
well then yuri fidgets i
guess i'll see you tomorrow wait i
kind of say that without thinking
about today
it's fine that we didn't have as much time as we wanted because
we can do this again
whenever you want you can come over we can go out somewhere i
forgot you don't like going at much i forgot that you got
okay we're asking her out this is good as i stumble over my words yuri simply smiled specially anyway
you know what i'm trying, to say so
you are very thoughtful ptp yuri takes a step closer to me then briefly squeezes my hand i
kind of like that about you
well
how am i supposed to respond to that i
Don't even get a chance to as
yuri suddenly pulls back
Sayuri, oh!
Oh, no
sayuri just know we weren't
It is to pay, to see hey?
Um well it's nice to see you i'm sorry but i i'm already on my way to leave
I'm sorry
but we'll all be together at the festival tomorrow so
That's so that's fine right if kids
sayuri beams
yeah, so
I'll see you tomorrow
clearly embarrassed yuri yuri stuff sayuri waits goodbye after her
So you're a i thought you didn't want to come over today
when i
treat seeing in meereen
But my imagination was being really mean to me so i had to come here in fiat for me see?
see what what are you talking about you know
how much fun you were having me jerry
and her till she got, to hear
me
yuri then you made such good friends
It's really nice to be pierce starts to fall down sayuri's face
On yuri that
what what did monica tell you monica monica was right about white
sayuri
what i said before is true i'm not gonna let this continue
caring about you like this is isn't that burden your mind is making it out to be
it's something that makes me happy it's something that i wouldn't trade for anything else
So even if it takes an entire lifetime i'm gonna be by your side until you don't feel any more pain
sayuri looks away i
put a hand on her shoulder to reassure her i'm scared ptp
i'm really steamed
what are you scared of siri
i'm scared that
they may like him more than you like me
sayuri it's three reasoning
and with you he can started to lately too much and you think you miss me
that's enough sayuri
But i want you to hurt anymore i slide my hand down so you always are and squeeze her hand in my own
Do you remember how i said i always know what's best for you do you still believe me
wordlessly sayuri nice
Even if you don't understand all your own feelings i know what you need the most right now and that's what i'm gonna give it
Going, to give to you oh?
Wow i gotta make a save here i'm making a save at all the choices so far there's only
it's really only two of them
friend-zoned you have to be honest you can't love someone out of sympathy you know
What you need the most if for things to be like they've always been?
monica told me the truth she told me how much happier you seemed after i joined the club i
know you're struggling with some really difficult feelings right now
but please trust me that i know what's best and what will make you happy in the end i
promise i'll help get things back the way they were
sayuri forces a smile through an incredibly pain expression
is this what it feels like to get stabbed in the chest i should write a poem about this
sorry it's okay this is just my punishment
remember
for being so selfish so please please don't worry about these stupid feelings i
Know you're right i know there's no, time that there's no happiness damn there please
That's why i came here just so i could get the answer and you need to heave and the other thing
You're also right that i just wanted to go back
To the way it was i realize didn't you i really do know you really do know me better than anyone btb
i'd trust you with anything
anything at all don't
Say, or a smile finally breaks all the sudden she turns around and dropped to her knees
sorry, i'm so sorry i don't know how to make that sound clutching her head with both hands she screams as loudly as, she can
I'm, so shocked i don't know how to act
react sarah looks over her shoulder and it flashes me one more weak smile before turning around and running off
sorry
I'm left helplessly standing in front of my house why am i feeling so horrible about this
there's nothing more that i could have done
and most i can do is support slavery through her feelings and help her on the path that's right
but
i'm having as much trouble understanding savories feeling as she is
Even though i can comprehend i keep wondering if i should be doing something more or something different
I know these thoughts will continue to plague me and so think so the way back the way they were i'm going
To give it everything i got
Sorry will always be my dearest friend and i'll do whatever it takes to put a smile on her face every day
it's the day of the festival
Of all days i expected this one, to be the one where i'll be walking?
to school would say orry but sarah isn't answering her phone i
Considered going to her house to wake her up but decided that's a little too much
meanwhile the preparation for the event should be nearly complete
The banner yuri and i painted is dry and i gently rolled it up to take with me
she sent me a pleasant text reminding me not to forget everything and i reassured her
funnily enough i probably feel the same way as natsuki about damon
I'm more excited for it to be over so i can spend time with say orion yuri at the festival
But, no one monica i'm sure the event will be great too
pizza pie you're the first one here thank you thanks for being early
sorry one sec i
feel like she's hot she's hiding something
for sure
that's funny i thought at least yuri would be here by now
monica is placing little booklets on each of the desk in the classroom
they must be
The ones she prepared that has all the poems were performing in the end i found a random poem online that i thought monica would
Like and submitted it so that's the one i'll be performing
i'm surprised you didn't bring sayuri with you yeah she overslept again that dummy
you think that on days this important she'd try a little harder i
say that but i suddenly remember what say or he told me yesterday
And i suddenly feel awful knowing it's not nearly that simple for her i only said it because it's the way i'm used to thinking
but maybe i should have gone to wake her up after all
hey
you should take you should take a little responsibility for her pitts peck i mean especially
after your exchange with her yesterday
you can't let her hang in this morning you know
exchange
monica you know about that of course i do i'm the club president after all
but i
stammered embarrassed
did say already really tell her about it that quickly
About, how i basically turned down her a confession that makes me really seem like the bad guy here but i'm the one who knows
what's best for her right
geez
you don't know the full story at all so
Don't worry i probably know a lot more than you think uh?
monica is being as friendly as usual but for some reason i felt a chill down my spine after hearing that
hey, why don't you check out the pantalets they came out really nice
yeah, sure i grabbed one of the pamphlets laid out on the desk oh yeah they really did
something like this will definitely help people take the club more seriously yeah that's a tear i
flipped through the pages each member's poem is neatly printed on his own page give it an almost professional feel i
recognise natsuki and yuri's poem from the ones they performed during our practice what's this i
Flip, to say yuri's poem it's different from the one she practiced
it's one that i haven't read before
oh
get out of my head before i do
What i know is best for you get out of my head before i listen to everything she said to me
get out of my head before i show you how much i love you get out of my head before i finish writing this poem
but a poem is never actually finished it just stops moving
Damn ah!
what is this
reading the poem i got a pit in my stomach
pizza pie butts wrap and nothing this poem feels completely different for anything else
sarah's written but more than that i
Changed my mind i'm going to get sorry so ah
well all right try not, to take too long, okay i
quickly leave the classroom don't strain you said monica calls that out after me i quickened my pace
what was i thinking i
Should have tried a bit harder for sayuri it's not a big deal at least to wait for her or help her wake up
Even the simple gesture walking her to school makes her really happy
besides i told her yesterday that things will be the same as they always have been
that's all she needs and what i want to give her i
read series house and knock on the door i don't expect an answer
since she's not picking up her phone either like yesterday i opened the door and let myself in
sorry
she really is a heavy sleeper i
swallow i can't believe i ended up doing this after all
waking her up in her own house isn't that more like something a boyfriend would do in any case it just feels right
outside say or his room i knock on her door
sayuri wake up dummy
there's no response i
Really didn't want to have to enter her room like this
isn't it kind of a breach of privacy
But, she really leaves me no choice i gently opened the door
oh
no
I don't know
i'm speechless i don't know what to be freaked out or sad or
an
exception has occurred
file game script chapter five line 307 c trace back text for details oh
my god
traceback
Paradis here's the text i found it i'm sorry but an uncaught exception occurred while running game code oh?
geez i didn't break anything did i hold on a sec i can probably fix this i i think actually you know what
This would probably be a lot easier if i just deleted her she's the one who's making this so difficult
well it goes nothing
cheese didn't break anything did i oh hold on a sec uh
Actually you know what it's probably be a lot easier i just deleted her she just wanted to make him this difficult here goes nothing
we're gonna, end that episode there i
i'll see you tomorrow with another episode squad 4